and I want to welcome to this video
playground our kannada our cardio
rotstein cardio or shine that's probably
those English pronunciation always a
little bit wacky if there is a
pronunciation that is kind of known to
me Alec typical German one like a water
sign on at least with a non-english
what's called intonation I don't know
internations for me wrong anyway and
we've gotten here into a Sicilian
basically by transposition and I'm
stopping you 45 m this line is some
believe to be ok for black it's funky
interesting so if I castle is going to
play Bishop age 6 it looks it looks at a
weird to me here somehow I mean I can
take you four and play green chair six
but I don't know if it makes much sense
I can classify bishop age six and then
play something like 98 it also looks a
bit weird
I feel like I should have something yeah
it looks like a strange move neglecting
development Queen to e7 maybe I don't
know
and Bishop h6 is annoying anyway I spend
too much time here in the opening as I
usually do when i try to refute strange
stuff and sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't this is kind of the normal
thing that you could play after no 10
seconds but yeah I tried I tried for
more so what should you i wonder if i
should actually play against this pawn
structure here i'm not sure about it
really not because this double porn is
not a big issue for him i cannot easily
attack it I think I want to keep this
Bishop and rather put it to the TM d 4
is a weakness so if i take on c3 this
weakness is going to be automatically
patched yeah so here you can actually um
try to allow him to take it's not
completely your take I think so I'm
trying trying that like a knight c 76-54
is a typical idea the structure is is
well known the only thing is that c5 is
weak and something like wintry 394 could
be an issue but I think I'm quick enough
this is why I went we need seven so that
I have this automatically um covered so
he wants to trade the light squared
Bishop soon that makes a lot of sense
actually
yeah it's not much that I can do about
it
I still have that night before idea but
it's probably not not nothin special i
also have to spend one more move like FF
6 cm to cover the e pawn and then i can
go to 9065 so he wants to play 93 to f5
I guess okay so going to jump to f5
shouldn't should be all that dangerous I
hope I feel famous last words yeah he
might play F for him but so long as I'm
only six that's not a problem
[Music]
the unprotected night only six is making
me slightly nervous but I don't think he
has anything there okay let's put it on
to deform this f5 this h4 h5 business is
a little bit a little bit off-putting so
I think I have to get rid of that need
to prevent h5 to h6 i still have looped
it for you time whatsoever put put this
on he's going to play some f for
business but i can also take with the
upon which is actually stronger making f
form useless okay so let's see this is
probably difficult difficult to play for
win but i will i will try our group d 6
doesn't do much actually anyway got 40
seconds a sister the main problem
position not so much
quite sure what the rook is doing them
basically nothing 30 seconds check
absolutely don't see what group chief is
doing my dear screen e5 through k1
Queenie one and made on h1 this is a
black idea and he still has the deep
Haunter to face what am i what am I
missing here maybe nothing but ok so he
tries counterplay so good move actually
have to take it unfortunate
main problem is again I have simply no
time Queen you're one years up to 70 for
some drawers hey where's the draw now I
don't see it as he just playing king
edge to or something magic hm
check check check
wyd forfeits on time I simply didn't get
anything that I think it was roughly
equal probably and then all of a sudden
it went downhill quite quickly okay
let's get some I want to have a quick
look at the opening this is between xi3
irritated immediate lot but probably I
don't have anything anything great
available yeah engine just wants to
cancel as I did yeah i was thinking like
I could take him this is not taken not
to g5 this but this is it doesn't feel
like reputation I mean black is ok but
it's nothing nothing special and I also
checked if I can maybe sex something
right age 5 or g six or so but it
doesn't feel right the engine plays this
which is interesting i was thinking here
and then queen 85 here this is the this
is a reputation idea going back in the
night vacuum that it's nice actually
maybe something like that is the key i
mean what i did is just like normal
normal moves just took me to me alone
while 222 great to get them yeah
allowing the double porn is kisses
thoroughly disliked by the engine yeah
maybe it is a a temper problem I mean
structurally speaking this isn't an
issue because I can get to deform i mean
if i can get to deform everything's cool
so yeah this is what to say engine give
and I don't totally trust it to have to
be honest in this position type because
it probably evaluates the double porn as
a
as a downside and I'm not sure that
there is any like an f6 now and f4 okay
something like that is can be an
argument if that works and then I'm in
trouble the time I have spent lots of
time with with all this and it is
possible that i just have problems
defending everything you have to note
that you for example has a pretty bad
piece yeah but it doesn't matter if i'm
liking this one move if he plays any
other move now I mean let's say
something like that and I'm completely
fine but it is possible i am the debts
that elect the time to get this set up
that probably makes this a dubious
decision of course black can just
instead take him with probably equal
play those engine also gives equal yeah
and now here it is probably equal dish I
mean I was fairly optimistic as usual
there's nothing much going on yeah I
felt I have to take it here okay rook g4
is given by the comp I was still kind of
fearful of age 6 even though it doesn't
really threaten I should have been
played hook before then went okay i did
this now yeah it here an interesting
moment i was thinking it takes this is
better and so so that f4 doesn't have
any any relevance like this this wasn't
clear to me maybe i can go to create I
mean yeah okay that's probably a good
alternative but this isn't bad I mean
I've got the protective porn and his
pawn structure here doesn't doesn't
threaten all that much o Queen g3 and
I'm losing what I can absolutely not
prevent Queen g6 and oakley aid yeah
it's an I'll hurry unlucky set up but he
missed that played this one
this is Ruby six I need to somehow
regroup but not like that so that was
very lucky ya hear that is really a
problem I can create your fix that's
just huge gym and my book has absolutely
no square and this and this is decisive
okay Queenie 80 bb-8 winning that's
strong check Queen d6 don't know might
why did I go to d6 actually I could have
ok I don't have much time but I can go
to the e-file direct line that that's
pretty strong and now the position is
bad really is p 3 1 strong way I needed
prick moves here with the check can't
the charm situation and it's not very
quick so i was happy with a simple
continuation ok guys thanks for watching